[Applause]
thank you I
you're very relaxed for such a scary
time in America no I want you to relax
we had a security sweep I've been
assured there are no bombs in the
monologue and ladies and gentlemen we
got him okay so that's the good news the
man who sent bombs pipe bombs to 12
people in an attempt this is what
happened in this country this week an
attempt to decimate the upper ranks of
one of America's major political parties
and it turned out to be he is exactly
what you thought an angry [ __ ] in a
red hat
[Applause]
oh he thinks Trump is the greatest human
being ever to live and of course he's
from Florida
and I couldn't make this up a stripper a
bomber who also strips experts experts
call this peak Florida Explorer no it
gets worse lives in Plantation Florida
no how was that still a name what was
slaveship Florida taken okay so so we
have we have a racist male stripper he
he worked under the name stormy trooper
Daniel's name name is Caesar Sayaka
like most Trump most of trumps friends
he's white over 50 a registered
Republican and has a long criminal
record please
he's also bankrupt has a creepy van
lives with his mom and last May the NRA
named him Lou Warner of the month sure
but he's he's been arrested eight times
eight times battery fraud drug
possession threatened to bomb the van
the creepy van he had had pictures of
Trump all over and make America great
and then pictures of Hillary and other
Democrats with their faces in crosshairs
is it okay to call this one deplorable
or would that hurt Republican feelings
cuz he was also a prolific hate tweeter
sometimes sending threats to Democrats
and he was frequently at Trump rallies
where he was known as a moderate no he's
a typical Trump loser blames everybody
else because his life sucks
that's who he is that's the profile
Trump's biggest supporters are always
some middle-aged guy whose package
doesn't work
Oh 4:12 with the bombs also I'm guessing
on a big believer in science in his
petition for bankruptcy in 2012 there
was a handwritten note attached which
said that he lives with his mom and has
no furniture and we know whose fault
that is Eric Holder and Hillary Clinton
Hillary what why do you want to blow
Hillary up she's not in office she lost
she has no power she's a grandma that's
its effect when the bomb squad was
opening the package she said save the
wrapping paper
but make no mistake what happened in
this country this guy wanted to wipe out
the top Democrats in America all the
major players got a bomb
o Baden Obama Biden Obama Biden the
Clintons Eric Holder poor Tim Kaine is
waiting by the mailbox Bernie Sanders
issued a statement what am I chopped
liver
[Applause]
anybody on Trump's [ __ ] list
got a bum CNN got one George Soros John
Brennan Robert De Niro Meryl Streep was
snubbed me nothing would you know look
that's good but I heard he was thinking
about it and it's it's an honor just to
be nominated
you know Trump is mad at the bomber to
not to get to the bombing because it
hurt his momentum he actually said this
out loud it hurt his momentum with the
midterm election because before we were
talking about my great Caravan the
caravan you know of the 7000 of these
desperate Honduran people who were
coming here only about half now are
still going if there's anyone left by
the time they get here they should get a
trophy I mean if this was white people
it would be on NBC sports I mean it they
call it the Ironman migrant race can't
we be a little kinder their goal is a
simple one they just want to make it to
Dodger Stadium for game for Republicans
and a bunch of panicky fear-based
babies Trump's cold closing argument is
what was that
Caliban brown shirts brown shorts is
more like it
I mean they're on foot there are over a
thousand miles away they're mostly women
and children on Fox News they're
tracking in a minute-by-minute like
there are a new bird driver coming off
it look at this 27 days away I can see
but let's not forget the bomber has been
caught and it's Halloween weekend I help
you yes absolutely we take it seriously
out here I've got a great costume I'm
putting a tiny orange dick in my mouth
[Applause]
and going as Sean Hannity